hey welcome to the monitor as always I
am Peter Reuben senior editor at wired
in this week what do we have we have a
television show that somehow manages to
not make me cringe we have a new comic
book that you should catch up on but
first we have the way I'm going to be
spending my Christmas Day and that is
seeing a young woman named Jane Gwen
chained django unchained from Quentin
Tarantino is hitting theaters next
Tuesday and yeah that's a few days from
now and if the Mayan apocalypse manages
to not happen we'll all be there but
this is the thing I am still looking
forward to perhaps most of anything this
year it is the story of course of a man
named Jango played by Jamie Foxx a slave
in the antebellum South who is freed by
a bounty hunter and trained in the art
of bounty hunting why to go rescue his
wife from an evil evil slave owner named
in Colonel candle or candy candle candle
candle Leo DiCaprio plays them that's
all we need to know anyway huge ensemble
cast as befits a clinton tarantino
production you've got Kerry Washington
you've got Christoph Waltz who we all
loved in inglourious basterds we have uh
Samuel Jackson of course it's far and
wide uh I kind of like this this revenge
kick that he's been on recently and by
recently I mean over the past few movies
inglourious basterds was an absolute joy
and I have been waiting for Jengo
Unchained since the day that we thought
Chris Tucker would be playing django but
it is not chris tucker it is Jamie Foxx
but it is still going to be a lot of fun
it opens on Tuesday I suggest you check
it out but not on my theater and don't
beat in food and being all loud about it
because I want to enjoy this in silence
let's talk about comic books there is a
comic book out this week that is
actually the the third and a four-issue
series but it made me realize that I
haven't spoken about this yet and I
would very much like to because I would
very much like you to discover and read
this book it is called multiple warheads
it's by a guy named brandon graham a
youngish writer illustrator based in
Vancouver now he wrote a one-off
multiple warhead book for Oni Press a
while back but this he has developed
those characters in the setting into a
four-issue miniseries as being published
an image it is the story of a
young in love couple sex akka and Nikoli
Nikoli is a werewolf and they are
fleeing their hometown in Russia but not
any Russia we would recognize it as a
sci-fi futuristic Russia and they are
they've gone for a road trip they packed
up they had to vacate their city and now
they are off to parts unknown now what's
so fantastic about this is there is this
a sense of whimsy that that pervades the
book Brandon Graham is really into puns
and wordplay and he fills his panels
with it this is a book that rewards
close reading like there is the story
that goes through but it's almost
secondary to the attention that he pays
to the denizens of this world every
character has these little one-off punny
one-liners I mean I am unabashedly a pun
nerd so I'm really getting off on this
book if you don't groan at every pun you
here and even actually even if you do
run it every pond you hear multiple
warheads might just be an undiscovered
joy for you this holiday season so check
that out multiple warheads three is out
this week but you can go back and read 1
and 2 which I would recommend don't
worry about the one off you can just
jump in with one and start there let's
talk about television so there was a
show on fuse I know right a show on fuse
not just videos of lady gaga there was a
show on fuse called Billy on the street
it's kind of a pop-culture game show
that is really the the structure of it
but I usually hate shows that involve
pranking or otherwise victimizing
defenseless people who have no idea what
they're getting into they didn't sign up
for this etcetera I don't like that
stuff but Billy on the street manages to
kind of ride that line where I never
cringe I never feel like this person is
taking being taken advantage of Billy is
kind of masterful at being really
abrasive and hilarious and not
alienating it's it's a magical balancing
act that he pulls off they rerun season
one all the time they had some guest
stars rashida Jones has been on they've
got some new ones plan for this season
it is if you ever catch it a billy on
the street' marathon just sit down for
one or two episodes and I can almost
guarantee that you will be hooked like I
have been in recent times but I'm very
excited about the new season and it is
back and I am rejoicing so that is it
for the monitor this week now tomorrow
is the last day it is not only the
winter solstice but it is the last day
of the current Mayan calendar cycle so
should the world end you can disregard
everything that I've said today about
Django Unchained and Billy on the street
but you should probably read multiple
warheads now just in case we all shuffle
off this mortal coil but we will be back
next week with a very special holiday
highlight reel you can always email us
at the monitor we will see you next week
but until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you